foreign
let's go to Paul and welcome to Miami
what's up Paul
hey how you doing Dr John I'm good man
what's up
oh not much uh live in a Jimmy Buffett
day and relaxing at home Cheeseburger in
Paradise baby that's right that's right
so what's up thank you for taking my
call you got
um I'm calling because my wife is a
self-diagnosed hypochondriac oh [ __ ] I
love you
and I'm sure your wife is awesome but I
think we can all agree that
self-diagnosed hypochondriacs whoa
and uh she also states she loves going
to the doctor
oh gosh
hey here's a
I'm saying oh gosh not because she's
dumb or a [ __ ] or somehow less than
I'm saying oh gosh because I know how
hard this is in your home and I know how
miserable it is for her and how
miserable it is for you y'all got little
ones too
nope no little ones not yet
um but uh oh boy thanks for the future
okay
so she's got Health anxieties Fair yes
yeah Health anxieties uh she she does
have General anxieties as well
um she gave me a list of active worries
that she has okay and then you always
say to lead with the big thing so I
could I could do both of those if you
like go for it
so uh to caveat she did say she does say
this started at a young age this
self-diagnosed hypochondriac sure um but
her active worries are all forms of
cancer okay heart failure blood clots
brain aneurysms covid any lung or heart
issues from covid and pneumonia to name
a few and the big day the big things are
three years ago her dad died of brain
cancer okay uh this past year her mom
was diagnosed with breast cancer okay
um in the years past her grandfather had
throat cancer and her grandmother has
COPD okay
so
um this is the the demon of anxiety
is uh
it's kinda right
right
so I don't want to parse apart health
anxiety versus generalized anxiety I
think that can be a an academic waste of
most of our time okay your wife
struggles from anxiety
I've been there debilitating it's hard
it messes up stuff
one of the things we've seen in the
medical community over the last 15 or 20
years is an increase of people with pain
disorders and who are struggling from
like I think oh I think my heart rate is
racing I need to go to the doctor
because often
that's the only place where somebody
stops what they're doing and puts their
phone down and looks at them in the eye
for 15 minutes or gently touches their
skin takes their blood pressure
right it's much more about human
interaction or it's as much about human
interaction as it is about the
diagnostic
okay
that's a body screaming for connectivity
um so she grew up as an anxious kid
where did that come from Mom Dad who
um well from what she's told me she did
have
um in my own opinion some significant
trauma through a childhood and she was
sexually abused by an older sibling I
know you've talked about screaming a lot
in uh for children and she was in a
household with a lot of screaming okay
and she's never been very close with her
mom okay so she's got a lot and that
sweet little body of hers okay and the
manifestation is some people dig holes
in the ground and create underground
bunkers
and some people hoard things and protect
themselves with stuff
and some people respond to anxiety
um by shutting the drawing the shades in
and get under the covers and netflixing
themselves to death
um I tried to solve my anxiety with
information
and so it's really cool to tell people
I've got two phds it's also a trauma
response okay it was me trying to prove
that I was smart and it was me trying to
get more data and more data and more
data and more data
she happens to try to solve her anxiety
from being
uh
over the top in tune with her
physiological functions to the point
that she's lost perspective
and she seeks the comfort of somebody
she views as wise and someone who finds
value in her which is a medical
professional or a nurse or a doctor
right
sure okay so
she's gonna have to decide
this is a person who uh
if I say if I say um I want you to write
your fears down and then demand evidence
from them
when you're in the throes of deep
anxiety she's got all the evidence she
needs every one of her family members
has died of cancer or has cancer right
that's right so she's got all the data
she needs yeah well we've talked about
that exactly because because we listen
to you every day and so we've talked
about that as a team together and she
says well I can find the evidence that's
right so yeah I'm gonna go back to
um something my buddy Todd told me and
I've told us I've mentioned on the show
and I'll mention it again because it was
such a shape shifter for me it might not
be helpful for anybody else
but one of my deep worries was the
implosion of the financial system
I didn't understand it I still I still
don't understand it but I didn't
especially understand it then and it
didn't make sense to me and things that
didn't make sense to me were a threat to
me and then I start trying to solve
things that didn't make sense to me and
that's even makes even less sense
because I don't even know how it works
I'm trying to solve something I don't
know how it works but
I was sitting down with him grilling him
one day and here's the other thing I'm
not dumb and there's the other thing
we're in the middle of a mat it was 2009
2010 during the middle of the madness so
I had all the evidence I need this whole
thing's going down this whole thing's a
sham this whole thing's on a house of
cards and we're going through this thing
and this thing I was like what about
this and what if this happens what if
this happens and then finally he said oh
dude I don't have a meteorite plan
and I was like what do you mean and he
said well I do all the things I know to
do right now which I carry no household
Consumer Debt he paid his house off
um I have this and I've got an emergency
fund and I don't have any debt on my
cars and I put money in retirement here
and I've got a couple of rent houses
over here
and then if the monetary system goes
away I'll deal with that when it happens
and for some reason it was a light bulb
moment for me because I wasn't taking
care of all the other things that I
actually could control I was just trying
to catch a spaceship which I couldn't do
and so I channeled my energy over time I
had to learn how to do this into all
right well I guess I'll go see a
counselor and I guess I will start
hanging out with my friends again
because I need relationships and I guess
I'll get my debts paid off because I
know that you can't be non-anxious if
you owe people money because your
brain's screaming at you you're not safe
You're Not Safe you're not safe
so I started taking care of the little
things and it was amazing
how the big stuff kind of evaporated
and here's what I mean in my house
I got a family history of cancers I got
a family history of heart stuff some of
it I didn't even know about until
recently
and so I get my blood taken every year
by a great doctor Dr Vickery and we go
through it and it's expensive we go
through the whole thing and he does a
incredible job my wife does too
and I take really good care of myself
best I can unless I'm having a gummy
candy day
and so I'm doing all the things that I
know to do
and then I'm gonna if I get throat
cancer I get throat cancer you know what
I mean I don't have a meteorite plan for
that after I'm gonna do the things
that I'm going to be intentional about
longevity so here's what I'm telling you
she's going to have to choose
to be less miserable in the present
not rehearsing tragedy for a thing that
may happen someday
sure right and and I think it comes down
I think some of it might be a control
thing as well
no no no I wouldn't go there I wouldn't
go there yeah it is but you're talking
about a little girl who is sexually
abused and that little girl's still in
there
so yes she is trying to seek control of
something because the things that we're
supposed to love her the most her
brother
her mom and dad they didn't show up
so yeah she's trying to control
everything I think my question would
come to how to be a good husband there
we go when when she brings up a concern
because I think I've gone through
different uh I don't know ways of trying
to support her best and and now I'm I'm
just wondering is if she comes with a
concern a health consumed a very
specific Health concern
what's the best way I could I could
support because right now what it is is
if she brings a very specific Health
concern I'll say okay well why don't we
go to a specific doctor and get that
checked out but I'm not sure if that is
a long-term solution no because that
becomes self-reinforcing
meaning
she gets anxious she gets anxious she
gets anxious y'all both go do a thing
that you know is really
not a good use of medical resources of
the doctor's time and of y'all's time
and money but you're gonna go do it
because it's gonna make her feel better
right this moment
and what it does is it reinforces the
anxiety that the way to feel better is
to go do this thing and then so your
body see what I'm saying it starts a
loop that your body's gonna start
seeking out these things every time
sure and so when I say the only way to
heal is through it
it's to uh oh I just woke up and I think
I'm I think I'm having fill in the blank
sure right and since we've already got a
blood test we're going to get a baseline
test since we've already got a cancer
screening since we've already done an
echocardiogram so and I am suggesting go
get a good Baseline like getting a great
blood to get a good Baseline
so that
um when the field I think this thing you
can roll back to
oh we just like 60 days ago we got this
great um Baseline here
yeah and we do we do annual physicals
great and and it came up to where uh
maybe a month ago she said well that's
been six or eight months ago you know
things can change
and so it's it's kind of it's kind of
like she would like to go again that's
right and so those are the moments
we are going to breathe and we're going
to head right into the storm meaning
we're going to feel that anxiousness
we're gonna know that our bodies are
okay
we're going to hold Loosely a meteorite
that might be coming you're right we
could have had 10 years of great blood
tests and then you got eight eight seven
eight months and then bam
stage four throat cancer
right right
um I'm not a cancer doctor
um but that's you see you you recognize
she recognizes how unlikely that is
right
yeah she does and and I've always I've
always said you know at any point if you
want me to help you find a therapist I'm
happy to but I know I can't push her
into it I know that from listening to
you it has to be a decision she has to
come to on her own right and so what we
need to do is when she's not anxious
we need to come up with a game plan that
y'all are both going to
shake hands and agree on
because just running to Specialists to
Specialists for the rest of her life is
going to become cost prohibitive and it
really is taking resources from somebody
else who needs to be there
sure and we don't want to blow over if
she actually is having an incident she
does have an increased risk for cancer
because she's got it in all of her
family members right right
um she does possibly have an increased
risk for filling the blank so sit down
with somebody and map that out
and I definitely think Cena counselor is
important I think if she won't go
then you go on your own and if she asks
you are you going tell her I want to
learn some better tools on how to
relationally connect with somebody who's
struggling so deeply from anxiety
what you're going to be tempted to do is
to create a Universe on your own
a world that's not crazy a world that's
a little more stable and what she's
going to do is feel you by degrees one
degree two degree Three Degree she's
going to feel you pulling away and
that's going to spark up the anxiety
even more
sure okay so when you say what's the
greatest thing you can do I can tell you
don't try to solve her as though she's
like an engine issue
lean in relationally and you'll have to
have already planned out what that looks
like when she comes to you and says I
think I'm having a stroke
already have planned out
all right let's hold hands both of them
I'll stop what I'm doing I'm closing all
the screens I'm turning the game off
even though it's the fourth quarter
there's only two minutes left I'm gonna
lean into this relationship
so we're gonna breathe together I'm
gonna connect with you together
and then once our breathing's under
control
then we're going to walk through okay
what are the three things are we gonna
go for a walk right now and while we're
walking we're gonna take five minutes of
just doing box breathing while we're
walking and then after minute five we'll
talk through symptoms
tell me why you think let's be curious
tell me why you think you're having a
stroke
yeah right and we're just gonna practice
that but listen you're you're right on
she's got to decide I want to be less
anxious
I want to heal from my anxiety
my health anxiety
and
ah jeez don't diagnose yourself as
hypochondriac please that's so hard
don't give yourself yet another label
yet another diagnosis
body's trying to keep you safe it has
been for a long time
and to your
to your wife Paul I'm sorry that her
family didn't show up for her family
hurt her
and she's lucky to have you a guy that
loves her so much
so we're gonna have some anxiety healing
and some trauma healing and some
practicing some new behaviors
to your sweet wife she's watching this
you deserve to be well and you deserve
to be loved and you deserve to stop
feeling like your body's failing you to
people in your life they did they failed
you they abused you they hurt you
screamed that [ __ ] made it your fault
but you're good
and you're whole
foreign